Hello and welcome to the second part of our exercise.
This is where we're actually going to be spawning some meshes into the world
so that we can start off with the creation of our forest.
This is where we left off. We have spawned a bunch of points by sampling the landscape
and all we have is two nodes at this point because we get landscape data
and the surface sampler. So let's have a look at the surface sampler.
Now you can see in the top right corner here we have a number of options available to us.
The main ones that are of interest are probably the points per squared meter. So this is going
to establish in each square meter how many points we're going to generate. At the moment
this is set to 0.1. I think we're going to leave it there, but you'll see here if I was to come in
and reduce the value to say 0.02 and we were to look at the world we would get even less here.
So if we increase the value we're going to have more and if we decrease the value it's
going to go down. The points extent this is going to show you how big our point mesh is
here. We're using the PCG cube but this can be swapped over. We could use a completely different
mesh and it would look completely different. I'd advise you stick with the cube really.
But it's going to show you the extent so this is going to change the size of them.
If I was to put in a thousand on the height here and check it out you're going to see we
could have a whole load of sticking up points and this will become more relevant as we're going
through. I'm going to reset that for the time being and let's actually do something with these
nodes. Turn this off. I'm going to drag out and I'm going to add in a static mesh spawner.
Now this node is going to allow us to actually spawn some meshes into the world
and with it selected in the details panel there is a couple of things that are worth us looking at.
Now the first one that I want to really look at is the mesh entries. You can see this is
an array under the mesh selector. I'm going to add in two entries here and this is going to
allow us to spawn or at least have a selection of two different meshes that it can select from.
Now you can open this up manually and under the descriptor you can find that we have the
static meshes here. What I'm going to do though is I am going to search at the top for static
mesh. The nice thing about this is it's just going to show me the static meshes so I can
manually select it without having to sort through all these drop-down boxes.
So for the first one I'm going to search for my bush and the second one I'm going to search for
my tree. Let's see, here you go, my tree. Okay, so we are selecting two meshes.
Now let's have a quick look at some of the other options here.
Now there are a lot of different options of how we are creating these and a couple of them
that are useful is for example we have the mobility ray tracing. We've also got the collision
setting. Now for the tree, for the bush I don't mind if we walk through it at this point,
however for the tree I would quite like the collision preset to block it. So I'm going to
type in collision and rather than no collision I'm just going to have a block wall.
Okay so that's just going to control how we do the collisions but there are lots of different
settings here. For example the shadows you might want to play with if you're looking to optimize,
especially for very very small things like the casting of casting shadows here.
That is very costly, can be very costly, so if you've got very small grass or something like
that it might be worth turning off shadows on it in order to get a slightly
to prevent having to pay that massive cost. So we have loads and loads of different settings here
all set by the mesh entries. One thing that I'd like to share is something that's called
weights. So you can see here we've got bushes and trees and if we have a look at the world
you can see that we have now a lot of trees. Okay, that's slightly too many. So
I'm going to change around a couple of different things here to reduce the amount of trees.
So the first thing is I'm going to increase the amount of bushes to the trees. So I'll make
two bushes to one tree, force regenerate, still two packed, a little bit less, but we have less
trees here. Now I'm going to go back to the surface sampler and rather than having 1.1,
I'm going to change this to 0.2. That looks a lot more reasonable. There you go,
so we've got fewer trees and a bunch of different bushes all scattered about.
Okay, so that is my starting of my forest. So you should hopefully be able to see something
similar to this. Don't worry, we're going to do a lot more with this, so it'll look a lot more
natural. But we're going to go through the problems sort of one piece, one selection at
a time. I'm going to drag this over here so that I can show what I think is our first
problem. Now you can see if we have a tree, it doesn't matter so much for the bushes,
but we have this tree. When it's creating the static mesh, it is using the ground normal
in order to determine the rotation. And that means we have a bunch of trees which are sticking
out of the side of the mountain. And trees in real life don't do this. They will grow
up towards the sun. They might take a little bit into consideration the ground,
but mostly they will ignore it. So that's one problem. The second problem is a lot of these
trees look very similar. And to try and make a natural forest, we want to try and make
everything look as different as possible. But we'd like to reduce the amount of meshes we use,
just because that way we can cut down on the cost of memory used. So we want to use one
mesh, but we want them to look as varied as possible. So what we're going to do is we are
going to jump in and we're going to add in another mesh. And this is when we're talking
about points again. So we've got our points here. And if I press E to disable this,
and if I press D on here so that we can look at what the points look like,
you can see that all of our points are at this moment flat. They're defined by the ground.
So you can see these are the ones that are causing us problems.
And they're all facing in exactly the same direction. So let's change this. What I'm going
to do is I'm going to jump over here. I'm going to hold down ALT and break this.
Now it's important we break it because I'll demonstrate why. But I want to transform these
points. I'm going to come in here and select a transform points. And now if I plug this in,
what we're going to be actually doing is duplicating these points,
because it's not automatically going to break this. Where if we were working normally with
an execution pin on Blueprints, we would be able to break, because you can only put one
execution pin in some circumstances. But most cases, it would break them.
Wherein this is just going to add them up. And what we're going to end up with is
a concatenation of the points. Just means it's going to duplicate it.
Okay. So I'm going to hold down ALT to left-click to get rid of that.
So let's have a look at this transform points that we have here. And you can see that we
have a number of different settings. And each of this, we have a offset for the location,
the rotation, and the scale. Now, what we want to do is we want to make these trees,
the trees' ambushes look as different as possible. So the first thing I'm going to do
with the offset is to try and avoid the oddness of the roots. I'm going to push it down.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to come in here and I'm going to put minus 20 and minus 20.
Now, you'll be able to note that there is a minimum offset and a maximum offset.
And this is because by default, it wants to give you a random value.
And so we've always got a maximum and a minimum for it to give you a random value in the range.
We want to make this consistent, so I'm just going to go with minus 20 for both.
Now, rotation is different. What I want to do is I'm going to rotate it by up to 360 degrees
on the Z axis. So this means that it will turn to any different degree. I'm also going to give
it a bit of a random tilt, but not much. Only up to 10% or 10 degrees. There you go.
Now, you'll see under this that we have absolute rotation or absolute offset or absolute scale.
This is because otherwise what it's going to be is it's going to be additive. So in the offset,
I don't want to set the location. I don't want to set the absolute location. I just want to
push it down a little bit. So I'm not going to tick that on. However, for the rotation,
I no longer want it to take the ground into consideration. So I am going to tick on
to have an absolute rotation. Now below this, we have scale. And what I'm going to do
is I want the scale to vary a little tree to tree. So the first thing I'm going to do
is these little padlocks. I'm going to switch these on because I want to keep it as a uniform
scale. I want to keep these consistent. And the first one I'm going to have as
0.8. And this one I am going to change to 1.2. We could have absolute scale here,
but it doesn't matter because it's defaulting to one. So it doesn't matter very much.
That's going to give us a level of randomness in the points. And because we put a randomness
in the points, that is going to be spread across to the static mesh spawner. I'm just going
to turn off the debug here. Actually, let's look at the debug on the transform points.
So you can now see it's a little bit subtle, but at least you can see that the rotation
is varied. But if we look at the ones that are sitting on here, they're now no longer
conforming to the landscape. They are just standing up straight. We're also pushed a
little bit down, but it's only subtle, so it's hard to see.
Okay. So now let's turn off the debug and turn on the static mesh spawner.
And let's have a look. Okay. And now our forest is looking at a forest. It's more of a wood.
But it's looking a lot more random, at least. Just the rotation of the trees make them look
like they are different trees. And the scaling up and down of the size makes it look a bit more
natural. So we have our trees and some bushes. Thank you for that. So we will stop
there at this point. And next up, we will be adding in some rocks. Okay. See you in the
next video.